one of the things many of you have been
writing to me and asking over the last
couple of weeks of the russian invasion
of ukraine has been some version of hey
david why do so many american
right-wingers love vladimir putin
and this is not a topic that has uh uh
slipped
the minds of many on the left who have
been wondering and asking about it
there's actually a couple of good
articles that you guys can check out one
such article by arwa madawi is an
opinion piece in the guardian called why
does putin have superfans among the u.s
right wing the sub-headline being the
russian leader is an autocrat
with a homophobic and misogynistic
worldview no wonder he's admired by so
many republicans pointing to essentially
um the the uh
governing and cultural similarities
between putin and what many
right-wingers would like to see
robert reich wrote in the guardian an
opinion piece called putinism is
breeding in the heart of repub of the
republican party make no mistake putin's
authoritarian neo-fascism
has rooted itself in america the cold
war has already come home
there are different reasons why
different right-wingers find putin to be
an appealing and interesting figure we
saw the video which i'm not going to
play again from the weekend at afpac
afpak was the openly white nationalist
counterpart to cpac
and at afpac one of their leaders nick
fuentes talked about um
russia has what russia has going for it
is uh young white men and they started
chanting putin putin putin and so for
some people what they like about putin
is
white
homophobic
trumpian reactionary
probably anti-semitic to some degree
uh leader
and putin antenato and trump antenato up
until two days ago remember that two
days
i mean this is so stupid but two days
ago trump started taking credit for nato
now that nato is seen as good because
it's uh on the side of ukraine now trump
after trying to crush nato when he was
president now trump says nato is good
but
up until before two days ago uh donald
trump and putin both very much anti-nato
and when you step back russia is sort of
what many of these republicans would
like to see the united states become
and what i mean by that is
they
like the idea
of
the authoritarian strong man gets to
decide who's president i mean that's
that's what putin essentially does
and it's what trump tried to do so that
that's very appealing to many trump
republicans
barely any
serious worker protections in russia
barely any environmental protections in
russia the rich can get away with paying
barely any taxes
through their cronyistic connections to
leadership
the government just openly tells media
what to do and they have a massive state
media apparatus that does their bidding
trump's trumpists and trump love that
stuff
um open homophobia and other uh uh
phobias that in the united states at
least to some degree you're still kind
of looked at as that's not really
appropriate if you just come out and say
a lot of the stuff
um a lot of uh
[Music]
um
sort of state assets that are privatized
controlled by oligarchs and
people get cushy contracts because
they're close to government all that
type of corruption
and cultural reactionary
infrastructure
that the united states
doesn't
fully have that many republicans would
like to see it have exists in russia it
exists in russia you can even kind of
make it even simpler
change would be bad
and keeping right wing white people in
control is good
i mean that that's like you could even
simplify it even more and you quickly
understand why there are so many right
wingers who love what is happening in uh
russia i think um one other thing that's
important to mention
is that not everybody in the trumpian
republican party openly supports putin a
lot of them
don't but they'll kind of talk around
the edges about
making sure that democracy works as
intended which remember is the same type
of code that the putin people use in
russia to justify their subjugation of
democracy to control elections it's it's
really really similar if you look at the
language and you look at the goals and
you look at the political orientation so
it's a serious topic
it's not just oh a lot of these
trumpists are enamored with putin yes
some of them are some of them not so
openly but the degree to which russia is
the image
of what we would get here if the
trumpists got their way whether or not
they say positive things about putin
should really scare all of us
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy dot com slash pacman the
link is right underneath this video